[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be discussing
a few different harry potter fan
theories however what sets these
particular theories apart is their truly
dark nature these aren't happy fan
theories these are the result of deep
diving into the darkest side of the law
harry potter can be innocent and
childlike but that certainly doesn't
mean that it's devoid or exempt from the
darker side of life with that said let's
dive into ranking my top 5 darkest harry
potter fan theories they're all pretty
dark but one has got to be darkest
number one voldemort possessed a fetus
this theory is certainly a crude one and
it essentially states that voldemort's
baby or rudimentary form that we see
pettigrew carrying around is the result
of fetus possession let me explain first
of all jk rowling has been quoted as
saying that the rough draft of the
goblet of fire made her editor sick to
her stomach if this is the case then
this rather gruesome theory is likely
the cause it starts with bertha jorkins
who was a witch and ministry of magic
employee she was a few years ahead of
james potter sirius black remus lupin
and peter pettigrew when she attended
hogwarts in 1994 bertha jorkins made the
unfortunate decision to take a trip to
albania as we know voldemort and
pettigrew were in albania at this exact
same time pettigrew a former pair of
jawkins convinced her to take a stroll
with him into the woods it was here that
voldemort who was hiding in albania at
the time tortured and murdered bertha as
we know in order to create a horcrux
murder is necessary so in killing bertha
voldemort was able to turn his snake
nagini into a horcrux
this is where the dark and twisted
theory comes into play the theory is
that when petticrew killed bertha she
was actually pregnant and the pettigrew
took the fetus from her corpse and it
was the same fetus that voldemort
possessed and petticrew dumped into the
cauldron to produce the regeneration
potion this of course means that the
body that we see pettigrew carrying
around is nothing more than a possessed
fetus and the unborn child of bertha
dawkins possession is one of the darkest
forms of magic and we know that
voldemort has mastered it so it might
just be a possibility
2. harry's grandparents james and lily
potter were murdered by voldemort at the
very young age of 21 so if james and
lilly were only 21 it should be very
safe to assume that some of harry's
grandparents would still be alive jk
rowling has stated and we've seen that
witches and wizards can live for a very
long time much longer than a normal
human so it always seems unusual that
harry wouldn't have a single grandparent
after all he should have four this
theory however discusses harry's lineage
on his mum's side the books have stated
that both of lily's parents died normal
muggle deaths without going into any
detail we know that they both died
sometime between 1971 and 1981 because
in 1971 they saw lily after hogwarts at
platform nine and three quarters and in
1981 lily was murdered we know them to
be dead at this point it's unusual that
they would have died in this time frame
and i'm really not sure what constitutes
a normal muggle death they weren't even
old what's a normal death cancer heart
attack it's really hard to say
provided that all of the information we
have on their deaths groups them
together and that they were so young i
suspect some foul play
lily and james potter were both very
outgoing witches and wizards joining the
order of the phoenix and actively
participating in the fight against evil
this meant that they were very much on
the radar of the death eaters in the
harry potter films we've seen many
instances of death eaters tyrannizing
muggle london and attacking muggles so
why would lilly's parents be an
exception
the theory is that because lily was so
prominent in the fight against evil
having defied voldemort three times she
made her family a target because her
parents were both muggles they would
have had no means of defending
themselves and the death eaters could
have visited them and ended their lives
instantly
in a deleted scene from harry potter and
the deathly hallows harry approaches
petunia and says the following in
reference to the death eaters they'll
torture you they think for a moment that
you know where i'm going they'll stop at
nothing to which he responds you think i
don't know what they're capable of to me
this implies that petunia knows more
about the wizarding world than
previously implied she's initially
painted as a little bit ignorant towards
everything going on but really i think
that she knows exactly what's happening
because she's experienced it before with
not only lily but her parents as well
3. jenny's love potion ah ginny and
harry two peas in a pod a truly
beautiful couple right well wait until
you hear this theory the theory put
quite succinctly is this ginny weasley
gave harry potter a love potion the
theory also suggests that harry and
ginny only end up together for that
reason and for that reason alone
there are a few reasonably credible
arguments for why this could in fact be
the case most of which i have rebuttals
to but for those you'll have to watch my
full video on this theory in the
description one of the main bases for
the theory is that harry seemingly fell
for ginny quite suddenly up until the
point at which they fell in love they
weren't particularly close nor were
there any direct indicators that they
would or should end up together one
moment harry's with cho chang in another
moment film harry is flirting with a
waitress at sweets cafe and the next
minute he's married to ginny with babies
so how could harry have become so
quickly infatuated with ginny the answer
a love potion
the main supporting argument for this
theory is that love potions have been
historically used by the weasley clan
maybe not for this purpose but used in
jest and in other serious circumstances
the bottom line is that love potions
have been used by them and they
certainly know how to make them ginny's
own mother molly admitted to using them
in her youth and fred and george sold
them so their perspective on these types
of potions can hardly be too severe the
love potion in question is called
amortentia a powerful love potion that
causes extreme infatuation or obsession
from the drinker not quite as romantic
as we initially thought
4. dumbledore let sirius rot in azkaban
as we know syria's black is imprisoned
in azkaban after he's framed for peter
pettigrew's crimes sirius ended up
spending 12 years in the island fortress
before escaping but one question that
fans have always asked is why was he
kept there for so long why wasn't he
bailed out why didn't dumbledore bail
him out the theory here is that
dumbledore didn't want to
dumbledore is portrayed in the books and
films as being a skilled legilimens
which means that he's essentially able
to read people's minds he was also the
chief warlock of the whizzing gamut
which gave him access to azkaban inmates
so my question is couldn't he have
easily just gone to azkaban and found
out the truth dumbledore's word was
enough to have snape's name cleared so
surely if he had found out the truth he
could have done something for sirius
didn't he owe that to him i think that
the potential morbid reality of this
situation is that dumbledore knew that
sirius was innocent all along but
allowed him to be imprisoned in azkaban
because he felt that his imprisonment
would be better for the wizarding world
as a whole here's why sirius black was
harry's godfather and being so close to
the potters would have likely taken
young harry under his wing after the
death of his parents if he were given a
trial i think that it's highly likely
that sirius would have claimed
guardianship over harry i also think
that it's particularly interesting that
sirius never got to trial at all
particularly as other death eaters did
it seems almost too convenient that he
never got a chance to speak his case as
though one of his allies had persuaded
the ministry that he was sure of black's
guilt dumbledore
but dumbledore never wanted sirius to
rot in azkaban for no reason he had a
purpose and his purpose came down to
baby harry and what harry would need to
achieve over the course of his lifetime
if sirius had taken guardianship of
harry he would have never lived with the
dursleys and though they were awful to
harry it may have actually kept him
alive because aunt petunia was harry's
blood relative it was believed that
lilly's act of sacrificial protection
would continue on and be transmitted
through petunia keeping harry safe
though harry would have been happier
with sirius he could never have been a
safe dumbledore didn't dislike sirius it
was just that in his eyes his
imprisonment was essential to secure the
fate of the wizarding world 5. harry's
imagination braced yourself because this
one has been floating around the
internet for a long time and is a bit
heartbreaking
i am of course talking about the theory
that hogwarts witches wizards magic ones
and broomsticks are purely a figment of
harry's imagination this theory is based
around the idea that harry a downtrodden
young boy had to imagine and create his
own reality a world that he could escape
to when his own world became too much to
handle
if we go by this theory the only real
aspects of the harry potter universe are
that harry lives with the dursleys and
that harry's parents are in fact dead
however if the magical world never
actually existed then it would of course
mean that harry's parents weren't killed
by the powerful lord voldemort they
really did just die in a car crash as
the dursleys always told him one thing
is for certain in both realities the
dursleys are awful to harry and
according to the theory it's their
nature that pushes him to the point of
creating his own imaginary world in the
harry potter books and films harry is
only left with the jerseys because by
staying with them it meant that he was
safe from voldemort the result of lily's
loving sacrifice
the only logical explanation for harry
staying with them in this other
circumstance is that harry simply didn't
have other family he had nowhere else to
go orphaned by a horrible car crash that
claimed the lives of both of his parents
harry was forced to go and live with
aunt petunia and uncle vernon oh and we
can't forget the awful dudley the
dursleys were truly awful to harry and i
have no doubt in my mind that their
behavior could push a young man who had
already lost his parents to the point of
well insanity to the point of creating
his own reality the following passage
from the book confirms that a harry had
no other family and that b he dreamed
and dreamed of his life changing for the
better when he had been younger harry
had dreamed and dreamed of some unknown
relation coming to take him away but it
had never happened the dursleys were his
only family now that's a dark theory if
you ask me what do you guys think of
these theories what are your top five
darkest harry potter fan theories
comment down below until next time it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you